wuz up guys
I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop
Wargaming has approached us about a sponsorship
opportunity to try out their awesome game World of Tanks and with that a chance to do a
Really cool build that goes along with the game here on the poopnch
We've got a powerful
RC car and a paintball gun and we are going to see what we can do to combine these two our goal for the day
Is to build a drivable fireable paintball gun that's decorated to look like a tank?
We'll try and get two of these tanks up and running and then we'll pit them against each other in a remote-controlled paintball battle
We've got our car, and we've got our gun. Let's see what it takes to match these two together first off
We're not going to need the decorative shell that's on top of this RC car. We'll take that off
The basic idea is we will mount our paintball gun onto the body of the car.
And then we will build a decorative tank body around the whole thing however
I think before we get around to mounting the gun onto the car body
We have to be sure that we've figured out a way to fire the gun remotely
I have here a small servo
Which I can connect on to the remote-control car, that should be able to be activated by the remote control and at that point
It would make something spin on here
so I need to hook this up to the gun in such a way that when this wheel spins it pulls the trigger on the
Gun before I attach the servo to the gun I need to be sure that it can be activated by the electronics in the car
Here we have the inside of the receiver for this remote-control car
This is what takes in signals from the controller
It makes the car do what you want this set of wires right here is actually something that controls the onboard
audio system
System this car will play
Driving noises as you drive. It around however. We don't need that right now so we can take this out and plug our servo in
Within the battery
All right now. We should at this point be able to turn this switch and have our servo move
Yep
That's moving so now we know we do have movement out of this thing
We can control it with the remote control
So we should be able to hook that up to pull the trigger on our paintball gun
I think the best bet for where to mount this servo is going to be inside the grip of the paintball gun so we'll remove
The side panels to the grip and see if there's a space where we can get this to stay inside Oh
Beautiful, okay, I think that's gonna work
I think we can just put a same screw that held the grip on back into the same
hole where it came from but use it to attach the servo to the gun as well and
Because it should be pressed up against the body of the gun when it's pulling against the trigger the resistance you just push it straight
Into the body of the gun and hold it in place that's fantastic well. Let's attach that screw and see if that's gonna work. Oh
My gosh. It's perfect. It's the perfect spot look at that that is attached that is sturdy
It's kind of right in between the two sides of the handle well
I couldn't have had that work out better if I'd planned it
We have this circle piece which we might be able to get to work
but the servo came with some other accessories including this arm so we can take this circle piece off and
Replace it with this and I think that might give us a little bit better leverage
Because it's a little farther away from our pivot point
So parallel to the trigger
I'm just gonna plug this back into the car for a second
We can see what kind of range of motion you actually get out of our circuit over here. Oh?
That should be plenty
So our arm will start right here
when we hit this switch
moves to there
and then back
beautiful
Well, I think I like that so let's secure this arm back down on to the servo
I've just got a piece of steel wire and we're gonna see what happens if we wrap one end of it around the trigger and
Then wrap another one through one of these holes in our servo arm
rock this back
Hey it fired. Oh
And now it slipped off the trigger again
So we definitely need to find a way to make it attach more securely to our trigger and of course
It's very loosely wrapped around the servo arm as well but proof of concept. This is working
I think the best way to get our wire to stay permanently
Attached to the trigger will be to cut a small notch into one side of it this trigger is made of aluminum and it's at
a bit of a weird angle
So we'll bust out the dremel and just cut a small notch into one side and that should make it so when the wires wrapped
Around it it can't slide off and farther on it'll hold a piece of wire from slipping quite nicely
All right now. Let's fit the wire into the notch that we cut
All right here we go
Ha that seems to be working great now
We know we can use our radio controller to fire off the gun we need to find a way to mount this to the body
Of the car, there's a couple of pieces that I want to move out of the way as well this right
Here is the line that lets you connect your compressed air tank onto your gun
But it's not in a very convenient spot for us, so I'm gonna try and move that out of the way
And then we might use an extension hose instead of this piece
Our paper gun is now stripped down
So there's this little hardware on there as possible and some of its going to need to be put back
But I think we should be able to mount the gun
Right here on the car. There is a threaded hole in the bottom of the handle
And I think we can probably use that as a mounting point to attach it to the back of our car
But that's not going to be enough support. We're definitely going to need more
Something holding this gun in place
So I think what we'll try doing is building a frame that
Connects to these points on the front and back of the car that normally hold the body of the car in place
I've got these two bars of aluminum
And I'm thinking I might be able to cut them down and drill some holes
To make them attach to the frame of the car with the same pins that usually hold the body on
Alright now let's see if these pieces will fit onto our frame
There we go
I
Think that'll work pretty well
nice and attached
strong enough lightweight
excellent now we can find a
Way to add a little bit more support. I'm thinking we'll want a support right under the trigger guard and
Then probably something that holds onto the barrel as well that should give us
Three different points of support, and I think that'll secure it to the car nicely
Excellent it'll give pretty good support right there now the piece that's gonna support the barrel
I'm really gonna want it to wrap all the way around so it gives side support and up and down support
So I'm gonna try and make a sort of horseshoe shaped piece and then attach a couple of support posts onto that horseshoe shape
Excellent let's make one more of those
Right there one right there same idea on the other side there
Excellent
All right our frame to support our paintball gun is basically finished all we need to do is
Attach the back of the handle onto the frame of the RC car I have a machine screw and a nut that will fit down
Through the bottom of the handle and then I'll drill a small hole into this part of the frame on the car
And I'll secure it to that
All right at this point we should have a drivable car
With a paintball gun mounted onto it you can see the action back here when I hit the switch
Slams forward once this is attached to some compressed air and we have our hopper full of paintballs on
This thing should be ready to go
It's not exactly fully automatic firing speeds, but this is supposed to be a tank
And I don't think most tanks have rapid-fire don't quote me on that. I'm not tank engineer
We removed the normal hardware for connecting our compressed air tank on to our gun that came out down here and attached to the bottom
of the handle
Since that's not there we have an extension hose that we're gonna use
Instead using this will let us put our air tank pretty much wherever we want instead of it having to be
mounted in just one particular spot I
Think I want our compressed air tank to sort of ride on this back bumper section
and then I'll try and add a little access door into the full cosmetic tank so I can take that out and
Refill it when it's running low. I have way more hose than is necessary, so I'm just gonna wrap this around the gun
And that still reaches back here quite easily good
That's where we wanted to come this is our tank of compressed air that attaches to this thing right here
And so I'll have it rest somewhere on
The back of the vehicle, so let's attach this and see how it goes
All right, that is open
So we should now be feeding air
Into the paintball gun which means if I fire it it should actually fire and now that has pressure it should reset itself
drivable paintball test here goes
See if we can drive it up
You can drive it back
And most importantly we can fire it
That was a great test the car drives. Well it shoots. Well and as soon as we have this hopper attached to it
We'll be able to shoot shot after shot. Everything is working great. It's driving
Well, so now all we need to do is make this look like a tank
I
have these evie a foam floor mats some contact cement and some razor blades and that's basically all I'm going to use to build the
Body of this tank I have some thinner sheets of evie a foam that are basically the same thing as the floor mats except well
Thinner and these won't be part of the main body of the build
But I will use some of this for detail work once. I have the general shape of the tank laid out now
This is the kind of thing that I wish I could show you an easy way to know how to build a tank out of
foam
But really there's a lot of eyeballing it guesswork
Making up measurements on the spot and a little bit of just hoping things are gonna work out
I have built several things out of this foam before so I have a good idea of how to cut it and glue it to
Make it into the shape that I want but for the most part. It's really just kind of watch what I do
I also have my computer on the workbench with me because I have an image of the tank
I'm trying to build up on my desktop
And I'm gonna be referencing that as I build the tank
While we're watching the montage of me building this tank let's talk about the sponsor that provided this opportunity
World of Tanks is a free online game that throws players into epic tank battles across
Incredible battlefields the game is set in the mid 20th century and gives players access to an impressive roster over
450 authentic tanks, there are over a hundred fifty million players worldwide, and they're waiting for you to join
This isn't just a game driving tanks around and blowing stuff up. There are a lot of great game
Elements to it your tank will evolve your tank can be upgraded and modified to enhance his performance
You can work as a team you take part in joint operations
You can engage in head-to-head duels that feel like any other co-op shooting game
There are regular updates bringing new content of the game and weekly special events to keep players engaged with evolving experiences
The tanks are true-to-life models and take their vehicle characteristics
From the authentic tanks of the time period for people trying out the game for the first time we recommend trying the Ru
Is-3 tank a close-range brawler that puts you in the middle of the action the first 300 new users to sign up with the code
ww2
Tanks will get three days of premium time 500
Gold and a free premium tank click the link in the description below and use your code to get started now
There you go the body of the tank is built this thing is entirely made out of craft foam and glue I use a contact
cement and I also used a hot glue gun for some of the detail work both of them have their different uses and
I think I'm pretty happy with how this thing is turned out. It's fairly lightweight as you can see and
So far I have hit it with a heat gun
That seals all the foam up so it will take paint much better than the first layer will be a layer of
Plasti Dip which is a sort of rubberized coating then I'll hit it with primer and then I'll start with the main color
After the main color is all applied
I'm gonna go in add a little bit of detail work to get the sort of grungy look that we have in the photo
I'll use a dark brown to give it a little bit of a dirty look
And then I'll use a little bit of silver to make it look like the paint has been worn away
And we can see the bare metal underneath in some spots
BAM
our tank is built our tank is painted our tank is mounted on a
remote-control car with a paintball gun inside, and it seems to me that there's only one thing that it needs a
Second tank for it to fight against we've got two of these bad boys and in our next video
We're gonna be taking these two out and pitting them against each other
We'll see which one ends up taking more damage and just how much a paintball will do to this floor mat foam that they're built
Out of thanks again to the sponsor of this video World of Tanks as a reminder the first
300 new users for the game using the code
Ww2 tanks will get three days premium playing time?
500 gold and a free premium tank check the link in the description to start playing now
Hey guys. Thanks for watching if you're not a subscriber yet
Just hit the bomb to get in the club if you missed our last video or want to see it again
Just click up here at the top click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks that you should watch next
That's it for now. Have fun. Be safe and see you tomorrow
you